okay so by now you've heard a lot of
positive things about App Engine and how
it can help you build scalable
applications but let's do a reality
check here surely there must also be
trade-offs involved when using App
Engine let's start off with programming
languages since App Engine provides
services to control the execution
environment it also has a set of
programming languages it supports this
list has been extended over time but App
Engine currently supports Python Java
PHP and go and since App Engine is an
execution container it also means that
there are specific versions of these
languages that are supported so this is
something to think about then moving
over to low-level controls since App
Engine was designed to create scalable
applications as easy as possible its
execution environment also encapsulate
many low-level controls for example
operating system type and version
virtual machine configuration or network
controls etc are not visible and cannot
be configured in App Engine and that
goes for other things as well App Engine
strikes a great balance between
providing the convenience you need to
develop scalable applications without
sacrificing the flexibility that you
want but with this in mind don't be
surprised later on when you see that App
Engine is not like a regular virtual
machine because it's not alright that's
it for the reality check let's now look
at some app engine success stories